amanda is with us in New Jersey hi
Amanda how are you I'm doing well I'm
actually from Tennessee not New Jersey
oh okay how can I help
so question regarding in-laws and debt
we are thirty three thousand dollars in
debt all in cars they bought us two of
those cars there and maybe step seven
they wanted to help us out so they paid
the for the cars in cash and then wanted
us to make payments to them yeah such a
blessing oh yeah so they made the
decision on the cars for you or you guys
pick the car out and I bought them for
you and asked them for we picked the
cars out they went shopping with us cuz
I want to make sure we made the right
decision so they bought them in cash and
now they're having us pay 600 a month
for both of the cars yeah so do your
in-laws for these cars in total we owe
them $25,000 and what is your household
income eighty-five thousand okay and so
how much other debt do you have other
than this and other than your mortgage
my husband also bought himself a car and
we owe seven thousand on that I'm sorry
so you have three cars well we bought
the first car so they his parents paid
for it in cash and then we decided we
got pregnant with our third baby and we
needed a minivan
so we traded that car in we took about a
$12,000 loss on it and we've got our van
so it's kind of a big screw-up so you
owe $7,000 on the van the van we owe
$13,000 okay so who's what's the $7,000
car
my husband's car how many cars do you
own we have two cars okay and you oh
you're on the two cars you owe your
in-laws $25,000 right plus plus $12,000
on a different car that we traded in
okay so you have 37 thousand dollars in
debt not count that's right
you have student loans credit cards no
no credit cards no student loans okay
and again your household income was what
eighty-five thousand okay so how fast
are you going to pay off thirty-seven
thousand dollars in debt we're hoping to
paid off by next year Christmas 18
months yes or 14 months or whatever okay
and is that a problem it's it's becoming
a problem with me in-laws kind of
monitoring everything that we do with
our money and making sure that we still
pay then which is not a problem but
every little expense that we pay for
ourselves it's like why do you pay that
much money may remember you still have a
car come into us so we kind of feel like
slaves to them okay yeah you are cuz
this is a really stupid arrangement okay
and they're and they're obviously very
controlling and have very bad boundaries
okay and you're really disgusted with
them I can tell by the whole
conversation alright and so the problem
is if you saw both cars I don't think
you get twenty five thousand would you
know okay do you have good enough credit
to go borrow twenty five thousand
dollars and pay them off yes okay let's
just go do that and get them out of your
life
okay just go down the credit Julie
thought of what yeah just go down the
credit union borrow twenty five thousand
dollars matter of fact you could borrow
just 37 on the two cars right and then
you know just put it on a 36 month
payment and pay it off by the next
Christmas right mm-hmm
same amount of time to get out of debt
except you get them out of your life
instantaneously except I would kind of
break the relationship
would it break the relationship the way
they have relationship with you is they
demand you're in debt to them they're
helping us no they're not helping you
they're a pain in the butt sure know
what the way it sounds is this mom and
dad listened we tried to do a good thing
here you were trying to be kind to us
but it's actually putting a strain on
our relationship and so in order for us
to be free from that and you guys not
have to worry about our finances anymore
we're just going to go ahead and take
out a loan and pay you guys off we
appreciate what you tried to do it just
didn't work out it's not working for us
and you know we love you and thanks for
trying thanks for playing
but we're not gonna do this if they get
pissed off at that these people have
other issues which I suspect they do by
the way but you need to pay them off and
do it as kindly and gently as you can
but if your relationship with them is
dependent on them fiddling around in
your checkbook all the time
it's time to draw that line and this is
a beautiful way to do it and then just
get about the business of paying it off
don't tell them your financial coach
advised that they don't know family
money I'm your financial coach and I
just advised you that because I tell
everybody that by the way